people often ask me how my parents
influenced me and I can't give a neutral
answer to that because I'm very much
influenced by saying bye hugs I think
that the biggest influence that parents
have on their children is at the moment
of conception I think that the people
often attribute far too much to parental
upbringing and there's a fair amount of
data from my field that not widely known
that suggests that the effect of parents
in shaping intellect and personality
might even be overrated you see this in
children of immigrants even if their
parents never acquired the language and
culture of the adopted country as long
as the kids were immersed in a peer
group they end up as fully competent
citizens something indeed that happened
to my own father the children of
immigrants who are culturally utterly
inept never managed to speak the
language in the case of my grandmother
were constantly at sea and figuring out
the culture my father grew up highly
successful so if you had asked the
question of him how did your parents
shape you he would have laughed he
shaped himself I don't want to deny
credit to my parents who brought me up
in a rich and stimulating household but
I think I'd be kind of inventing a
novelistic autobiography which is I
think what most people do when asked how
did your parents influence you that
having been said it was a house with
with books with discussion with
arguments with people coming in and
challenging us with interesting ideas so
I wouldn't have traded it for anything
but the scientist in me says that warns
against my own tendency to tell a story
and how it explained Who I am today
it's natural to to credit who you are
with your parents it seems like an act
of decency or gratitude in fact I often
have to apologize to my parents saying I
really do appreciate everything you did
to me it's just that the scientific data
lead me to think that parents don't
shape children as much as most people
think and their attitude is I should
give them credit for their attitude
which is we would want you to say
anything but what you believe based on
the best scientific evidence that that
you take seriously so don't try to
fashion your answer to have to flatter
us I think that that is a sign of the
kind of people that they are they are I
think as interested in ideas and in
providing good reasons for your ideas as
I am I don't know whether I inherited
that whether they fostered it in me but
they deserve full credit for that
even if perhaps by the standards of
their friends I seem to be denying them
credit and in talking about theories of
the shaping of personality
I think the only way to make sense of
nature and nurture his person most
obviously to point out that these are
not alternatives that you couldn't have
nurture that is the creation and
transmission of culture without a rich
system of emotion and learning to make
sense of it to create the culture to
acquire the culture if you're faced with
it learning it as a child and in the
other direction it would be a pretty
useless kind of innate human nature if
it couldn't take in information from the
environment if it couldn't figure out
the kind of physical and social world
that had been placed in and soaking up
information as to how to to prosper in
it in order to so you need both how do
they interact more than half you have to
specify I think the innate motivational
systems the innate learning mechanisms
that make learning and transmission of
culture possible so something is innate
what is innate is not concrete behaviors
or chunks of knowledge what is innate is
an ability to analyze the world and to
learn in certain ways language makes it
concrete we could not possibly be born
with English on the other hand just an
ability to learn generically isn't
enough because you can take a baby and
you could take a cat or a parrot give
them the same environment the baby will
learn to speak the cat won't
so something unique must be there as
well in the case of language it would be
a motive and an ability to analyze the
signals coming out of someone else's
mouth as being formed out of units that
have fixed meanings within a community
and combinatorial rules that allow new
ideas to be expressed by arranging these
fixed signals in different orders and
combinations the brain mechanism that is
equipped to do that to find the words
the nouns the verbs the phrases to
analyze speech as having that logic
that's what's innate not just a generic
ability to learn at one extreme not
knowledge of English at the other
extreme